dressed as often referred to as the city
of science due to its high concentration
of research centers in the region being
part of this international research
community has enabled me to make strong
collaborations and I've learned a lot
from professors and researchers here my
name is Laura Shabana I was born in
Maribor in Slovenia and I studied
pharmacy in Ljubljana
as a PhD student I spent some semesters
in Strasbourg and Trieste and here I
also successfully applied for a positive
position three years ago on a European
project transfer Caravan I'm also
currently employed
in our search will could bilirubin which
is produced in our cells and released
into the blood bilirubin has a strong
antioxidant activity and thus protects
one's health status the bilirubin level
in the blood can vary according to the
individual's lifestyle as for example
their diet body weight stress or sports
I very much enjoy the cultural exchange
to learning Italian Italian culture and
Italian cuisine while I mean interest
I've made new friendships with people
from all over Europe who are currently
working here year largeman has made it
possible to live and work in a foreign
country and easily exchange panik's and
ideas with researchers from other
European countries I'm sure that our
research will have a positive impact on
the health of all Europeans